it's like 1:00 in the afternoon where
the are all these people going if
you guys watch me lose my
here hopefully I'm gonna say something
and it's gonna make some of you oh I do
that maybe I won't do that anymore and
then I won't be such a psycho is that
what I'm trying I don't know what I'm
trying to do here it's the way I want to
be he's about a block and a half away
and this is gonna take me every bit of
like 17 minutes to get there
I mean we've literally been sitting here
for like 20 lights somebody
should be over turned it on fire up here
for the level of traffic that's
going on where are all of these
people going like one of the advantages
of being a stand-up comedian is that
everybody's at work during the day and I
should be able to just cruise around
throwing rose petals out the
goddamn window and how wide open it is
it just never happens I work from
Holland I started a business it's
it's a goddamn baby could crawl
on the sidewalk and get there
faster
this really is stupid
I'm not gonna make a love to who's gonna
let me in whose gun how about you you're
gonna let me in you're gonna let me in
course not why would you let me in
you could go another two feet let me in
thank you thank you maybe I still do the
way if you even though you didn't
let me in this is why I never
want to leave my house I love my wife
but she always does that like we
should do something today today be a
good day to do something and it's just
like yeah I would love to if wouldn't
take four hours to get to the
something and by the time I get there I
want to kill myself I can't imagine
living in like Nebraska and they just
hey you want to do something today and
you just get in your car and you drive
and you go do it
after all most people out here just got
sick of driving that's what it is it's
pulled over and just said to hell with
it
I can't do this I just can't do
it I don't give a I'm gonna find
some other way
what how do i back this up all right
back
people hate me right now people hate me